thank you very much for joining us i'm
john langler shane mccolonis
is back back in the community he swore
to defend back in the valley where his
family is prepared now
to help him recover from being shot on
the job it's been 10 months since the
metro officer was critically injured
after a protest on the las vegas strip
kate houston is live here in the studio
with the latest from his family
kate yes today i spoke to shea's
stepfather patrick neville
he says shea is back home and now able
to talk
this is great news after the shooting
happened doctors were not sure if he'd
ever speak
again shea has been home for a few weeks
after staying at a medical facility in
denver which specializes in spinal cord
injuries
his family says he's still paralyzed and
on a ventilator
now shay is going through a transitional
period to adjust to in-home care
his family says being back in his
hometown is a great moral boost for him
and they're so happy he's close since
he's been home he's been able to see
friends
and enjoy the fresh air after months of
rehab in his hospital room
in his house he can just go out his
bedroom
door and he's in his backyard his
friends can come over and visit with him
he gets to see people we've taken to the
station so he can see his squad members
um so i think that's really positive for
shay and just to be able to small things
that a lot of people
don't realize is just be able to go
outside
is really a big deal moving forward the
focus is to get shay
stronger and to see him progress even
further
neville says he'd like for shay to also
be around people who are dealing with
the same mobility restrictions
neville says the support from the las
vegas community and from around the
nation
has been outstanding his family is
making sure he sees all of the calls
texts and letters back to you